là où ça bouge au bord de l'eau ce soir
pour vous présenter les artistes de la
région va suivre le courant de
l'actualité musicale
en normandie on vous a déjà parlé de
samba de la muerte très très bel album
spleen l'ancien j'ai du slam maquillait
de rock également big sister voilà pour
les groupes qu'on vous a déjà présenté
mme il y en a d'autres et ce sont des
artistes de la région et non pas
régionaux car ils peuvent s'exporter un
peu partout dans le monde
exemple avec ce groupe de la branche
autres ode 56 c'est du rockabilly à
l'ancienne et ça a été enregistré
figurez-vous à los angeles avec un
technicien de l'époque pour obtenir le
son des années 50
écouter un petit peu voilà
je
un petit lit est fourni avec alors je
vais leur entrée dans la non bertrand
réseau non non ça ne rentre pas on
continue avec un disque très personnel
celui de katell est la risée cet album
dans des conditions un peu particulières
au cours de sa vie c'est terriblement
humain c'est terriblement touchant je
vous conseille vraiment d'écouter katell
les femmes encore à l'honneur avec cet
excellent disque de l'ina d'oran quand
vous avez présenté déjà dans là où ça
bouge ça s'appelle la gitane alors que
je parle je parle mais il faut peut-être
d'écouté ali chante en anglais
en arabe mais également en français
ils sont 3 patrick simon daniel
guillotin et thierry marie pour un album
électro mais je dirais on y retrouve
aussi des influences de pink floyd ou
dark eyes c'est vraiment un disque
découverte assez exceptionnel si vous
aimez l'électron qui vous laisse comme
ça un peu planer avec des aussi des gros
sont des grosses guitares et temps en
temps des envolées aériennes
j'ai noté aussi que le mixage a été fait
par quelqu'un du big band café
excellence et sylvain champions je
trouve qu'il a vraiment réussi à très
très bien mixer cet album est le groupe
qu'on adore jésus christ fashion barbe
il y a des coeurs il ya la voix ils sont
quatre ça déménage c'est du rock au
chant choral matinée de 2,2 folk
également vraiment un très grand disque
et c'est marrant parce que ça fait des
années qu'on les voit sur les scènes de
la région mais aussi de france et c'est
leur premier disque
les jeunes artistes s'intéressent aussi
à la musique classique c'est déjà le 20e
festival de pâques des samedis jusqu'au
7 mai neuf dates pour la musique de
chambre et vocale à deauville
non
un américain en normandie on a déjà vu
ça
on revoit sa encore avec des vitraux
américain québec en a mais la musique
américaine entre autres
et
oh
vient enfin si on répète mozart
des vitraux vit aux états unis mais il
est anglais il a déjà conduit
l'orchestré régional de normandie
il parle de sa seconde maison mais hors
castes française et en particulier cet
orchestre et une sensibilité
particulière là pour la couleur et
j'apprécie beaucoup ça je viens encore
une arrivée
j'apporte le rythme des deux styles
naturel américain que je connais pas ce
que je vis la barre des 6 mai s'est
mélangé avec une approche française qui
donne une nouvelle sensation
on
mozart donc bernstein les guerres
chouine sont au programme de deux
concerts opium samedi et à 40 ans
dimanche